hello I'm Terry Terry Pierce and I've
been making telescope mirrors for quite
a number of years now more than forty
and run telescope making classes to show
other people how to do the same thing
[Music]
when we're talking about making a mirror
the opticians hundreds and hundreds of
years ago used different grades of sand
which is nowadays called really Emery
powder so they would take their metal
mirror they would grind it to curve with
the coarse grinding sand
they would make it smoother and smoother
with finer and finer grains of sand
until they had a very very smooth
surface and then by the time you've
finished in you're on the very very
finest grinding poverty it's
unbelievably smooth beautiful smooth
silky finish to it they would then have
an absorbent surface like pitch or even
paper or silk or taffeta so the idea is
you put the pitch onto the grinding tool
or a similar circular disc that pitch is
molded to match the curve of your mirror
that you've ground very finely
once that pitch is hard and said you put
your very very fine polishing powder
onto your mirror then you start
polishing the powder beds into the pitch
it doesn't roll around it just sits
there
and microscopically it acts like a plane
and it would make the surface go shiny
again and you are aiming to make an
optical surface which is accurate to
about a millionth of an inch to polish
your mirrors at least four five six
hours of work the one thing you must do
is not to keep looking at the clock
because what you think is ten minutes is
only one minute passed
there are various mentions of mirror
makers earlier mirror makers even
Herschel for example as far as I can
gather once he'd got started on
polishing a mirror he dare not stop me
to work ten twelve sixteen hours without
stopping with his sister helping and
feeding him while he carried on
polishing away on his mirror to get this
absolute perfect optical finish a mirror
the size of the one we are making here
was the size of the one that Herschel
used to discover the planet Uranus with
and a little disk that size properly
made if you point it at the moon that we
show you craters on the moon no more
than the mile across and it will show
you cracks on the moon probably about as
wide as the River Thames and all from a
little polished piece of piece of metal
cast ground polished by hand
you